AND SINEMA.
>> Harris: TOM HOMAN IS WITH ME
NOW.
FIRST OF ALL WHEN YOU SEE THAT
VIDEO OF THE LITTLE ONE HOLDING
HIS TEDDY BEAR SCREAMING AT
THOSE SMUGGLERS WHO LEFT HIM
BEHIND I KNOW YOU WILL TELL US
THAT YOU ARE NOT SURPRISED BY
THAT BUT IT IS HEART SHAKING.
>> IT IS HEART SHAKING.
AND WHY I FIGHT SO HARD, HARRIS
AND WHY I HAVE GOTTEN -- I GET
EMOTIONAL ON THIS NETWORK
SOMETIME.
ALMOST 35 YEARS I'VE DEALT WITH
MANY SAD THINGS.
I'VE DEALT WITH DYING CHILDREN.
THE GOOD THINGS IS THE BORDER
PATROL AGENTS ARE RESCUING THE
CHILDREN.
I'VE BEEN DOWN THERE FOUR TIMES
THIS YEAR AND THEY JUMPED IN
THE RIVER TO SAVE DYING
CHILDREN AND JUMP IN THE RIVER
UNABLE TO SAVE A CHILD AND THEY
DROWNED.
THE MEN AND WOMEN OF BORDER
PATROL OR THE ONLY PEOPLE OF
HUMANITY ON THE BOARD.
TELL ME THAT'S HUMANE TO WATCH
THAT VIDEO.
CHILDREN BEING DROPPED OVER THE
WALL.
ABANDONED ON RANCHS.
MOST INHUMANE POLICY I'VE SEEN.
THANK GOD FOR THE MEN AND WOMEN
IN GREEN SAVING 4,000 LIVES
LAST YEAR.
>> Harris: YOU KNOW, I DO WANT
TO ASK THIS BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
YOU HAVE SAID THAT A NATIONAL
SECURITY RISK IS THE NEXT STEP
IN ALL OF THIS AND THAT IT
WOULD BE GREAT, ARE WE THERE
YET?
>> WE'RE THERE.
THAT'S WHY I THINK GOVERNOR
ABBOTT IS DECLARING A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY.
HIS TROOPERS HAVE SEIZED A
RECORD AMOUNT OF FENTANYL.
THAT SPREADS ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY KILLED OVER 64,000
AMERICANS DURING THE LAST
CRISIS ON THE BORDER.
THE REPLY, THE CRIMINAL CARTELS
CONTROL THE MEXICAN/U.S. BORDER
AND JOE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
HANDED IT TO THEM.
THEY USED THIS HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS.
PUSH HUNDREDS OF FAMILIES AND
TIE UP THE BORDER PATROL AND
THEN GET THE DRUGS IN.
NOT HOW MANY PEOPLE ON THE
F.B.I. WATCH LIST HAVE GOTTEN
IN SUCCESSFULLY.
IT IS A SEVERE NATIONAL
SECURITY CRISIS.
>> Harris: WE'RE SO FOCUSED ON
THE LITTLE ONE WHO HAS BEEN
ABANDONED BY SMUGGLERS.
I IMAGINE EVERYBODY WAS FOCUSED
ON THAT CHILD AND THAT CREATES
A PERFORATED AREA, ONE THAT YOU
CAN EASILY CROSS THROUGH FOR
CARTELS AND SMUGGLERS.
I TOTALLY GET WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING TOM HOMAN.
THAT BECOMES THEN A NECESSARY
DISTRACTION BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO
GO TO THAT CHILD.
BOY, IT SOUNDS LIKE THEY KNOW
WHAT THEY ARE DOING IN TERMS OF
POKING HOLES AT US.
I WANT TO GET TO THIS.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" HAS
OBTAINED DOCUMENTS REVEALING
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S PLANS TO
OVERHAUL THE IMMIGRATION SYSTEM.
APPARENTLY HE IS ABOUT TO PUSH
TO ALLOW MORE PEOPLE INTO THE
UNITED STATES AIMING TO UNDO
MUCH OF PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
LEGACY.
FORMER WHITE HOUSE SENIOR
ADVISOR STEVEN MILLER WITH THIS
SEARING RESPONSE TO THE MOVE.
BOTTOM LINE, YOU HAVE WEALTHY
AND PRIVILEGED WHITE HOUSE
STAFF WORKING TO DEMOLISH THE
PROTECTIONS ORDINARY WORKING
PEOPLE RELY UPON WITHOUT AN
OUNCE OF EMPATHY OR CONCERN FOR
THEIR WELL-BEING.
TOM, YOUR REACTION.
>> I AGREE WITH STEVE.
I THINK OF ANOTHER THING.
I THINK THEY ARE GROWING GAS ON
A FLAME ALREADY.
SHOW ME ONE THING, ONE THING
THAT ADMINISTRATION HAS DONE TO
SLOW THE FLOW.
THEY'RE NOT.
THEY ARE GETTING GOOD AT
RELEASING PEOPLE QUICKLY AND
BRAGGING ABOUT IT.
NO OVERCROWDING.
WE'RE MOVING THEM QUICKLY.
WHEN YOU BRAG ABOUT RELEASING
PEOPLE QUICKLY AND BRAG ABOUT
OPENING UP MORE POLICY TO BRING
MORE PEOPLE IN WHAT WILL THAT
DO?
YOU ARE THROWING GAS ON THE
FIRE.
IT WILL BRING MORE PEOPLE AND
MORE ENTICEMENT.
IT EQUALS FREE HEALTHCARE AND
NO DETENTION AND QUICK RELEASE
EQUALS DACA AND AMNESTY AND NOW
INSTEAD OF TALKING ABOUT
CONSEQUENCE OR DETERRENTS.
INSTEAD OF DOING ONE THING,
JUST ONE THING TO SLOW THE FLOW
SO WE DON'T SEE WHAT WE SAW
WITH THIS LITTLE CHILD.
WE DON'T SEE DYING CHILDREN AND
WOMEN BEING RAPED AND CARTELS
MAKING BILLIONS THEY THROW OUT
ANOTHER ENTICEMENT.
THEY DOUBLE DOWN ON THE WORST
OF THE WORST.
THEY HAVE ABANDON THEIR OLD AND
MEN AND WOMEN OF THE BORDER
PATROL.
YOU CAN HATE OR LOVE PRESIDENT
TRUMP, I DON'T CARE WHAT PEOPLE
THINK.
YOU CAN'T DENY THAT HE GAVE US
THE MOST SECURE BORDER IN MY
CAREER AND BY DOING SO ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION WENT DOWN 80%.
HOW MANY WOMEN DIDN'T GET RAPED
AND HOW MANY CHILDREN DIDN'T
GET ABANDONED AND HOW MANY
AMERICANS DIDN'T DIE OF
OVERDOSES AND HOW MANY MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS DID THE CARTEL NOT
MAKE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID IT RIGHT.
AGREE OR DISAGREE PRESIDENT
BIDEN UNDID ALL OF THAT AND
PUTS THE COUNTRY AT GREAT RISK.
PEOPLE ARE DYING ON THE BORDER.
>> Harris: YOU REST THAT ON THE
SHOULDERS OF THE PRESIDENT.
WHEN HE HANDED THE JOB OFF TO
THE VICE PRESIDENT YOU WOULD
THINK MAYBE THAT PERSON WOULD
DO SOMETHING.
IT GOES BACK TO THE PRESIDENT.
LOOK WHAT WE ARE LEARNING ABOUT
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS'S TEAM.
REPORTEDLY PANICKED WHEN
PRESIDENT BIDEN GAVE HER THE
BORDER ASSIGNMENT AND HER TEAM
HAS REPORTEDLY TRIED TO
DISTANCE HER FROM THE SOUTHERN
BORDER CRISIS BECAUSE SHE WANTS
POLITICAL VICTORIES.
CNN REPORTING THE STORY AND
OFFERING THIS TAKE.
>> REPUBLICANS KIND OF SEIZED
ON THAT CONFUSION AND THEY MADE
IT SEEM AS THOUGH VICE
PRESIDENT HARRIS WAS GOING TO
BE THE NEW BORDER CZAR.
HER ROLE WAS ALWAYS GOING TO BE
FOCUSING ON THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE COUNTRIES AND THEY SAW
HER BEING LINKED TO THE BORDER
AS A PERILOUS ASSIGNMENT AND
TASK.
SHE HAS WANTED TO EMPHASIZE
BOTH INTERNALLY AND PUBLICLY
HER TEAM HAS COME OUT AND SAID
PUBLICLY LOOK, WE DON'T OWN THE
ISSUES AT THE BORDER.
WE ARE NOT MANAGING THE ISSUES
AT THE BORDER.
>> Harris: IT SOUNDS LIKE THE
VICE PRESIDENT'S TEAM CHOSE
POLITICS OVER ALL PEOPLE.
THOSE SOUTH OF THE BORDER WHO
HAVE SUFFERED THE WAY YOU
DESCRIBED, TOM, AND THOSE OF US
WHO EXPECT HER TO DO HER JOB
BECAUSE IT'S AMERICA AND WE'RE
CITIZENS.
>> I DON'T CARE WHAT CNN SAYS.
SHE IS THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
HER RESPONSIBILITY IS PROTECT
THIS NATION.
HER RESPONSIBILITY IS TO THIS
COUNTRY AND OUR SECURITY AND
OUR SAFETY.
AND SECURING THAT BORDER IS A
PART OF THAT JOB.
SO SHE IS THE VICE PRESIDENT,
BOTTOM LINE.
SHE IS RESPONSIBLE.
SHE WILL WEAR THIS TRAGEDY.
HER AND THE PRESIDENT AND THE
SECRETARY WILL WEAR THIS
TRAGEDY AND THEY SHOULD BECAUSE
THEY HAVE PUT THIS OPEN BORDERS
AGENDA, THIS ISN'T
MISMANAGEMENT.
THIS ISN'T INCOMPETENCE.
THIS IS BY DESIGN.
THIS IS WHAT OPEN BORDERS LOOKS
LIKE.
THEY GAVE IT ALL UP TO WIN AN
ELECTION FOR THE PROGRESSIVE
LEFT.
>> Harris: WE'VE ENTERED THE
NATIONAL SECURITY RISK ZONE AND
YOU SAY IT IS A DIRE SITUATION
ALREADY WHICH IS WHY WE SAW
TEXAS GOVERNOR ABBOTT DECLARE A
DISASTER DOWN IN HIS STATE.
SO THE NEXT STEPS IN ALL OF
THIS ARE COMING AND TOM HOMAN
WE'LL HAVE YOU BACK TO
UNFORTUNATELY NAVIGATE THIS.
ALWAYS GREAT TO